negándose a Rendirse la planta de acero
azoftal es uno de los últimos focos de
resistencia del ultranacionalista
batallonazov conocidos en mariupol y
ahora es el foco de los bombardeos rusos
en la ciudad portuaria arrasada mientras
Moscú intensifica su ofensiva para tomar
el este de Ucrania
junto a lo que queda de la resistencia
de la ciudad también Se informa que hay
más de mil civiles refugiándose bajo
tierra
hay cientos de civiles en la fábrica
asostal entre ellos hay muchas mujeres
niños y ancianos los ocupantes rusos son
conscientes de que hay civiles aquí pero
siguen lanzando bombas de fragmentación
cohetes y todos los proyectiles de
artillería posibles incluso desde buques
de guerra
hizo un llamamiento a los líderes
mundiales para que impulsen un corredor
humanitario que permita a los civiles
huir y a las familias enterrar a sus
muertos con dignidad funcionarios de
kiev dijeron que aviones de guerra rusos
se preparaban para lanzar bombas de 5
toneladas sobre la planta de azoftal
tras casi dos meses invadiendo Ucrania
las tropas de Vladimir Putin se han
visto obligadas a reagruparse ya han
anunciado el inicio de una nueva fase de
la guerra enfocada en lo que llaman la
liberación del dombas la ciudad clave de
maripol les permitiría completar un
puente terrestre entre la Península de
crimea ocupada y las fuerzas en las
regiones separatistas de doniach
kilogans